l'arrivée massive dans notre vie
quotidienne des microprocesseurs c'est à
dire de tout petits ordinateurs par la
taille mais aux étonnants de
possibilités cette arrivée va modifier
notre façon de vivre
or personne ne peut répondre pour
l'instant à la question les ordinateurs
vont ils créent plus d'emplois qu'il
n'en supprime
bilan des expériences pilotes des pme
aux grandes administrations côté pour
performance de rapidité qualité facilité
aux des contres fatigue des yeux avec
l'écran parfois remplacée par une seule
ligne difficultés de la réorganisation
et craintes générales pour l'emploi
l'arrivée de ces machines soulève une
multitude de difficultés pour
l'adaptation l'organisation l'emploi et
l'apprentissage d'un nouveau système est
changé transmettre enregistrer des
informations
vite bien partout est devenu une
nécessité face à ce marché les
constructeurs d'ordinateurs ont ouvert
une nouvelle voie celle du portable
apple présente le portable macintosh qui
est une réponse à la demande
ce portable est un véritable ordinateur
à la place de la souris une boule pour
diriger les programmes un écran de 640
par 406 elle à cristaux liquides dont
chaque point est piloté par un
transistor les prix 40 mille francs hors
taxes pour la version de base la
révolution électronique dans les bureaux
demandera des années et sera sorti une
révolution
douceur